اخوتي واخواتي الكرام اسعد الله مسائكم
بكل خير من هنا من ارض الشمال نسو فيكم في
اخر تطورات في البلاد معكم عبود ب نبدا
حلقتنا يا اخوان اليوم يمكن 87 على الحرب
على قطاع غزه يعني على مدار 88 يوم ولليوم
اصلا فش دواء في المستشفيات وفيش حتى
اطباء يعني اللي ماخدوش اليهود قتلوه
فاهمين علي وعلى مدار 88 يوم بناشد في
حقوق الانسان انهم يتدخلوا او يعملوا شيء
مش مدورين علينا احنا اليوم قررنا انه
الناشد حقوق الحياه اخوان انه يشوف
الحيوانات في قطاع غزه يشوفوا البسس
يشوفوا الطيور شوفوا اي شيء في غزه اللي
قاعدين بيموتوا من الفسفور الابيض ومن كل
شيء يرموه علينا يعني ما خوش شيء ناقص
يرموا النو و بيختموا علينا كل شيء فاهمين
علي فحنا بناشد في حقوق الحيوان يشوفوا
الحيوانات في قطاع غزه لانه اللي ما ماتتش
من القصف ومن الفسفور ومن ومن ومن لا اخره
ماتت من الجوع من العطش يعني احنا مش
ملقين اكل وشرب البسس بده لاقن الطيور بده
يلاق فيش شيء مش عارف انا ايش بدي احكي
لكم بس
والله